يضاعفون اسطولهم البحري وفرنسا
والمانيا تعترفا. لا بد على من
التفاوض مع بوتين لانهاء هذه
الحرب. الدبابات تتدفق الى
اوكرانيا والهند تعلن عن مواجهة
الدب الروسي. فما كل هذه الفوضى?
بايدن يرفض المبادرة والغرب يعلن
انسحاب قوات كييب من باخموت فما
هو التالي? رعب امريكي من سلاح
صيني قد يغير مجرى الحرب
الاوكرانية. والاوروبيون يتجهون
نحو الصين لحل ازماتهم والولايات
المتحدة تعلن رسميا عن مواجهات
مباشرة مع بكين فوق الاجواء
الصينية. وفي المكسيك تاجر
مخدرات برتبة وزير. وايران تمد
سوريا قاتل ضد الكيان
الاسرائيلي. الضربات الروسية
تتوالى. نشوة الهجمات الروسية
على الاراضي الاوكرانية لا
تنتهي. ومن جديد صفارات الانذار
تدوي في جميع المدن الاوكرانية.
ونيران المعارك تصرخ. هل من
مزيد? نعم القوات الروسية تكثف
ضرباتها وهجماتها على مواقع
القوات الاوكرانية في عموم
البلاد قيادة الاركان الاوكرانية
ان قواتها صدت اكثر من سبعين
هجوما روسيا على عدة محاور خلال
ساعات عدة. لتأتي المفاجأة
الروسية من البحر هذه المرة. حيث
صرحت قيادة عمليات الجنوب
الاوكراني. ان القوات الروسية
تستعد لشن هجوم صاروخي على
اوكرانيا من البحر الاسود. مضيفة
ان الفرقاطة ادمرن مكاروف توجهت
الى البحر الاسود وعلى متنها
ثمان صواريخ. ليضيف الجيش
الاوكراني ان روسيا ضاعفت عدد
السفن العاملة في البحر الاسود
متوقعا ان يكون هذا استعدادا
لمزيد من الضربات الصاروخية.
ليعترف مسؤولون غربيون
واوكرانيون ان قوات كييف قد تضطر
للانسحاب من باخموت بعد تعمد
الاوكران التقليل من القيمة
الاستراتيجية للمدينة وذلك بحسب
صحيفة تايمز. فما كان من قوات
المتبقية في باخموت الا ان نسفت
سدا مائيا لاعاقة تقدم الجيش
الروسي وفق وسائل الاعلام
الروسية فما هكذا تؤكل الكتف
ايها الاوكران. لتنهال الدبابات
الغربية على اوكرانيا. وبعد
المانيا وفنلندا او ما بولندا
وكندا ترسل كل منهما اربع دبابات
لكييف وفق وكالة انباي انترفاكس
كوين الاوكرانية. فما كل هذا
السخاء من البر الى البحر يبسط
الروس سيطرتهم. فخلال عام من
الحرب استطاعت القوات الروسية
السيطرة على كامل شواطئ بحر
الزوف في اوكرانيا لتشكل تلك
المناطق خطوط الامداد بين القرم
واقليم دومباز. لتجد فرنسا
والمانيا الحلال لاوكرانيا. حيث
نصحت باريس وبرلين اوكرانيا
بضرورة الانخراط في محادثات سلام
مع روسيا وسط مخاوف غربية من
تداعي استمرار الحرب على كييف
بحسب صحيفة بول ستريت جورنال.
وهنا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف يقول ان
من يدعمون اوكرانيا سيلجأون
للتفاوض عاجلا ام اجلا من اجل
تسوية الوضع. وهو ما يدركه
الامريكان ايضا حيث قال مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سوليفان ان واشنطن تحافظ على
خطوط اتصال مع روسيا لمنع رفع
التصعيد. اذا ماذا يأخذكم الغرور
يا هؤلاء؟ عليكم الذهاب الى
طاولة السلام وهو اقرب الطرق
واسهلها. الا تفهمون؟ وعند ذكر
السلام والمفاوضات تظهر امامنا
خطة الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا
لكن هذه الخطة تقف بين التشكيك
والقبول والرفض. فموقف واشنطن
يبدو فاترا بين التردد والرفض
كما هو حال بايدن الذي قال ان
فكرة تفاوض الصين على نتائج في
اوكرانيا غير عقلانية. مضيفا ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يصفق له. فكيف يمكن ان تكون جيدة
فلا مستفيدة من الحرب غير روسيا
على حد قوله وذلك لقناة اي بي سي
نيوز. اما زينونيسكي فرحب ببعض
البنود لوقف اطلاق النار لكنه
قال ان بلاده التي تدور فيها
الحرب هي من يجب ان تطلق خطة
السلام ليطالب زيلانسكس بان تضمن
ان تغادر روسيا الاراضي
الاوكرانية. بينما شكرت موسكو
الجهود الصينية لاجل السلام.
واشترطت عدم المساس بالمناطق
الاوكرانية الاربع التي ضمتها
مؤخرا. فالى اين تتجه هذه الحرب
والى اين ستصل مبادرة اصحاب
العيون الضيقة ليجيب زالنسكي ان
اوكرانيا تنتصر وحدها ولا يمكن
لدولة الوقوف بمفردها امام هذا
العدوان حسب تعبير ليضيف انه لا
يعتقد ان لدى الصين عرضا حقيقيا
لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا.
ليكشف زيلينسكي انه يخطط للقاء
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ
قريبا. لكن رئيس شيشان رمضان
قديروف يقول انه لا فائدة من
المفاوضات مع كييف لانها دمية في
يد لارب حسب قوله. ليخرج مساعد
وزير الداخلية الاوكراني مصرحا
بوتين خسر ولكننا لم ننتصر بعد.
انا رايح فين ؟ انا راجع تاني.
ليضيف نحن نحتاج للكثير من
الاسلحة للانتصار على روسيا.
مهلا يا صديقي. فقانون الحرب
يقول هناك شيئان لا ثالث لهما.
وان تكون منتصرا او مهزوما فلا
يوجد طرف خاسر وطرف لم ينتصر
لننتقل الى حرب التحالفات وفي
تطور لافت لموقف نيودلهي. اكدت
الهند على معظم اعضاء مجموعة
العشرين المطالب بضرورة انسحاب
روسيا الكامل وغير المشروط من
كافة الاراضي الاوكرانية. لا
تستغرب من موقف الهند فهي على
خلاف كبير مع الصين والصين هي
حليفة روسيا الاقرب. ليعود هنا
بايدن ويستبعد ارسال مقاتلات اف
ستة عشر لاوكرانيا في الوقت
الحالي. اذا واشنطن لا تجرؤ على
امداد كييف بالطائرات. لكن هنالك
ما يؤرق الامريكان اكثر ويجعلهم
يشعرون بقلق متزايد. انه ارسال
الصين باسلحة تتضمن طائرة بدون
طيار طلبتها موسكو من بكين. قد
تغير هذه الطائرات مسار الحرب
الاوكرانية بجانب ذخيرة تحتاجها
القوات الروسية العاملة في
الصفوف الامامية وفق صحيفة بول
ستريت جورنال. الغرب يلجأون
للشرق. الحرب اوكرانيا والصراخ
في اوروبا. والغرب يتجه نحو
الشرق لايجاد مخرج لهم. نعم هنا
اوروبا تتحرك شرقا بحثا عن حلول
للازمات والحروب التي وقعت على
اراضيها. وسعيا لتضييق الخناق
اكثر على روسيا. فالرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون يعلن انه سيزور
بكين مطلع ابريل المقبل لبحث سبل
وقف الحرب في اوكرانيا وبناء
السلام. ليتزامن مع زيارة مماثلة
للمستشار الالماني اولف شولز الى
الهند تناولت ملف الطاقة وزيادة
الضغوط على موسكو. فهل ينقذ
الشرقيون الغرب من تلك الازمات
ومن حرب البقاء الى معارك
الفضاء. حيث تندلع مناوشات
ومواجهات بين مقاتلة صينية
وطائرة استطلاع تابعة للبحرية
الامريكية فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي
ليقول مسؤولون امريكيون انها
المواجهات اصبحت شبه يومية واكثر
خطورة بحسب صحيفة بول ستريت
جورنال. فهل حان وقت اندلاع
الحرب الكبرى بين المارد
الامريكي والتنين الصيني ولمن
ستكون الغلابة عندها? الاحداث
والتطورات. بعد تسجيل لارضيتين
جديدتين في تركيا جاء الدور على
اسطنبول لتخلي المباني تحسبا
للزلزال بعد انهيار فاجئ لطريق
في بنديك. وزير الامن المكسيكي
السابق يواجه حكما بالسجن بعد
ادانته بتجارة المخدرات. السلطة
وتجارة المخدرات معا حاميها
حراميها كما يقولون. افاد
التليفزيون الرسمي الايراني ان
طهران ستزود سوريا بسلاح دفاع
جوي بهدف مواجهة طائرات اسرائيل
التي تواصل استهداف مواقع سورية
وايرانية بشكل دوري. مبادرة
الصين بين رفض وقبول وتردد. فهل
تنجح هذه المبادرة ام ان لاطراف
الحرب رأيا اخر?